foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
than yesterday yes so I can breathe I
apologize I probably I think I told you
guys we'd have to walk like a Joe Biden
Bengals period but that's tomorrow oh
okay so rapey Cosby was the best we
could do today
or as we refer to it way better than
John Leguizamo philan hosting for Trevor
Noah villain hosting all week we'll be
talking about that on Rumble I don't
know if you've seen the current state of
late night and the numbers and the
material it's just it's it's a it's a
pride swallowing Siege we thought they
were the just the YouTube numbers oh my
gosh they're like oh that's the show so
uh a little less intense today than
yesterday but still there's a lot of
misinformation going around there
regarding the Nashville shooting so we
have an update on that we also have an
update on the tick tock bill now keep in
mind that's very different from the
hearings that we were discussing I
believe on Monday the bill that has been
passed here's the deal if you have
almost all like universally approved or
supported a bill by Republicans and
Democrats I mean get the get the astral
glad you were about to get screwed
and this is the Patriot Act for the
internet so to be clear when we were
saying yeah Chinese spyware bad that
needs to be banned for the protection of
the privacy of Americans instead we have
a Tick-Tock bill that's been supported
from the left my left ear right and the
right that completely invades your
privacy uh I don't know if we can unring
this Bell yeah anything that's
co-sponsored by Mitt Romney should raise
red flags yes yes exactly a matter of
fact I don't believe in red flag laws
except except for Mitt Romney in this
case yeah
Auto categories like on YouTube where
it's like for hateful content for
misconduct for Mitt Romney check
if there ever was a case so are we
talking about that uh DeSantis by the
way just passed an education Bill School
vouchers we're fans of and we'll be
talking about John Leguizamo Tick Tock
but before we move on my question to you
for today is
two things first off what's your take on
the Nashville shooter potentially
swapping shoes this is going out there
and you know it could be a complete
conspiracy right or do you think that it
does raise some questions and the fact
that it's not being acknowledged by any
but that's one of those things that's
where people start putting on their
tinfoil hats because there's no
transparency also look I'm going to take
an unpopular stance today but just
listen to me this was not a hate crime
Nashville I don't want to use the I
don't want to use the left's language
it's terrorism terrorism is enough hate
crimp a crime terrorism murder does not
need a footnote
so let's not start using the language of
the left that's not going to turn out
how you want it to comment below all
right Gerald hey how are you Mr CEO I am
doing much better today how are you good
it's a meat locker in here it feels
really cool I feel nice and cozy yeah I
don't know well like my nipples could
cut class did you sleep last night a
little bit
I find myself envious of my little ones
when they sleep like 13 hours yeah where
a part of me just wants to wake them up
vengefully we all like you when you're
like four and a half to five hours of
sleep because you're just pissed off
enough you can usually throw that into a
story yeah exactly so I'm ornery
I like an old man speaking of which hey
Dodge twins are gonna be back in
tomorrow but Pop's Crowder is in third
chair today how are you sir thanks he
gets a title I get old man that's my
lead it says Legends yeah Legend yes
Legend all right good what else do you
want by the way papa is a p-a-p-p-a I
think Popa I don't know I have no idea
but I know he speaks too far away from
the microphone
okay no no The Hodgetwins are back
tomorrow that we thought they needed a
little bit of a breather after yesterday
we have some sketches to tape yeah and
we also are preparing tomorrow a dump
button uh for for rumble for the Hodge
twins wow so really yeah across the
board what are they advocating a crime
no it's just you know it's just The
Hodgetwins there's nothing it's just you
never know what's good the second I hear
hey man I'm like this is gonna be bad
I've never heard the n-word so much in
my life I know I know and we're at
certain point we get uncomfortable as
white guys and I had a racist
grandmother yeah
well we all had a racist background yeah
Kevin said we lost that way for a while
but we're back and I said oh back to
your roots Steven said don't say Roots
don't say Roots don't say Remember the
Titans uh all right
don't say whatever that swim movie was
with Terence Howard don't say Hillary
Swank when she goes in and teaches it
don't say Dangerous Minds wait a swim
movie yeah there's a swim movie come on
yeah
I don't necessarily know how much we
were stopping them from swimming so much
as they weren't swimming not our faults
all right
so it's a show Monday through Friday 10
a.m Eastern notifications don't work on
YouTube subscriptions don't work your
best bet is to head on over to rumble
but just bookmark the page Rumble and of
course Friday is only on mug Club Monday
through Friday 10 a.m Eastern which
really means 10 10 because you guys tune
in late
let's move on right now as this uh this
is uh just so you know this is a a
transgender individual
uh portly gets ready for a big night out
on the town
join me as I get ready for my lgbtqia
events that I'm really excited for
people ask me how all the time how do I
do my makeup they just practice makes
perfect I don't look like a Las Vegas
showgirl I'm not doing it right what
snacks to bring like I want to bring you
the little that's a scooter he's on a
scooter the worst thing about having to
wear a mask is
um having to put it over your earrings I
don't know that's a struggle beautiful
look because you're
like I feel like my true self and I
don't feel that that often on both
inside and out so hold on let's let's be
really clear here right we always talk
we used to tell kids it's a that beauty
is skin deep and I feel you know I never
feel like myself I'm very unhappy but
now that I put on some some makeup yeah
and some some braids I feel superficial
accoutrements of being now I really now
I'm authentic really how can you tell
children that it's what's on the inside
that counts and then say or you can
change everything about you with a
little bit of Mimi eye shadow
don't forget the earrings don't forget
the earrings can we go back can you show
us that by the way just so you know and
this will tie into the Nashville shooter
because it's important while we're
talking about mental health we're
talking about overall health that person
is on a scooter in Walmart that's a
scooter look at that angle yeah that's
not very healthy and that mask is not
protecting you from anything honey you
can hear it can you hear it let's play
it again you can hear it I got to figure
out what snacks to bring yes I want to
bring you the good old Sun Chips Harvest
here it's struggling
now to really play against type though
he would have been in the produce aisle
and not the processor I
diet is the meal the sides of your hand
and I do the perimeters
oh God stop eating bunions
you know what this would go great with
pork rinds and I'm gonna stuff that into
my pork yes you're going to a two-hour
show you don't need to bring your own
snacks it's a real struggle to put in my
earrings because of my sausage fingers
I love the trumpian kind of everybody
always asks me yeah
everybody asked me how I do my makeup
Naomi Campbell came up and I was like
again the nurse it's narcissism with
anybody else going look at me look if
you see a woman right everyone mocks the
woman doing makeup on Instagram on Tick
Tock the Instagram ass models right this
is not healthy for young women we've all
talked about that unrealistic Beauty
Body standards but when you have someone
who looks like Mimi from The Drew Carey
Show
Brave and beautiful golf back everybody
everybody Golf Club everybody golf is
down no
and here's the thing the comorbidity
factor with people who are suffer from
gender dysphoria it's it's it's
virtually 100 just so you know we've had
uh Dr Boniface one time on the show a
long time ago back in 2015 talk about
treating many people and saying that a
lot that like socialized anxiety
disorder depression bipolar it is so
high in this community and that's
exactly what we found out with the
Nashville shooter so you don't have to
say that the trans thing might lend
itself to a 42 attempted suicide rate
though it does you just say hey it lends
itself to other comorbidities if you're
talking about red flag laws which again
I don't necessarily agree with uh okay
also by the way one month free mug Club
lighters.com head on over and watch
there that's that's the place that we
ask you because you won't see anything
Friday unless you are a member and on
Mud Club and it's it's free membership
but you do have to be sign up to be a
thing okay
that's because I know we're talking
about buying next so I'm getting into
and Daniel really yeah yeah you want to
get into it start stuttering you ass so
done Joe Biden and here's the thing just
for some context next year okay people
have been trying to say well hold on a
second if you've seen the clip where he
talks about ice cream he didn't know
about the shooting yet and I don't just
want to score political points I
understand that sometimes you have to
soften the blow and you have to do some
crowd work I get it but the issue here
is that it's not true he did know about
it it had been addressed and he went on
far longer about ice cream than
appropriate to the point where there's
no longer punch lines his age was like
do we need to get him some ice cream too
is this something's happening is this a
cry
for pecan Sandy ice cream I don't think
so crowd work is that what we're calling
it now that's not a joke
which brings us to this week in Biden oh
wait if you have a problem
mayor Trump and you ain't black my name
is Joe Biden
I'm Dr Joe Biden's husband
and I Jenny's ice cream chocolate chip
I came down because you heard there was
chocolate chip ice cream
by the way I have a whole refrigerator
pool upstairs I think I'm kidding I'm
not cut Ben how are you pal one of the
best guys in the United States Congress
Ben carton
folks uh
welcome to the White House
and it's too late to have you all here
and who are those good-looking kids back
there
I just want to speak very briefly about
the school shooting in Nashville
Tennessee
if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or Trump and you
ain't black
two things
um
one there's a there's a crowd out I mean
you're laughing at his name
I'm Joe Biden
I think it was surprised he remembered
yeah exactly yeah what are you what are
you Bill Maher's audience are you a
bunch of trains so he says his name goes
on for ice cream way longer I like ice
cream like okay okay that's fine I like
chocolate chip oh okay I got some
upstairs in the fridge
all right fine sometimes I have
different variety but you think I'm
joking we don't think you're joking we
think you're
and then the lack of self-awareness look
yeah the former Vice President Joe Biden
when it comes to really liking uh like
kids just say nothing
he's out and coming out and be like hey
you want to get some coffee I'm just
getting ready I was like no hold on
that's not a p don't Veer into it
because people think you're a 35-time
rapist don't Veer into it why because
you you we've you've been caught on
camera for like two hours at a time on
the Christmas reel sniffing small
children so let's just sit let's call
that a third rail for you you think I'm
joking yeah I that actually frustrates
me I've never I haven't seen this yet
because I thought maybe maybe like okay
maybe they went to him at the wrong time
maybe when Fox cut to him to address the
Nashville shooting and he did a
monologue on ice cream they cut to him
at the wrong time and that was Fox's
fault right I thought that was possible
right and he wasn't ready to I didn't
realize and I said guys check because
did he go into talking about the
Nashville shooting right after that like
if that's your plan and I get that this
was a different conference address that
at the out set like that just sounds an
entertainment show we felt the need to
do it and by the way there's still all
kinds of horribly inappropriate jokes
and material with the Hodge twins but
you have to address it otherwise
everyone else is really uncomfortable
and just to to issue that so the claim
right that you are seeing out there
right now this is from the left the
issue here is truth that's the theme
that he was unaware of the shooting at
the time you're seeing this across
social media that's it well here's the
truth he did know about it he knew about
it hours in advance how do I know unless
there's absolutely no communication
there which very well could be the case
we have to allow for that the White
House Press Secretary Karen yeah
I already addressed the issue with
reporters so we're seeing the
heartbreaking news of another shooting
of innocent school children
this time in Nashville Tennessee
the president has been briefed on the
situation and our team is in contact
with doj and local officials about what
is known so far
well shoot
that seems pretty cut and dry yeah yeah
knew about it knew about it but ice
cream and by the way when when former
Vice President Joe Biden says I'm not
joking that means he's lying to you you
ever met someone who says well to be
honest you're going what were you before
what were you saying before like a
mechanics as well to tell you the truth
well what were you saying when you just
told me I needed a 2300 new transmission
no now I'm telling the truth
do you see that interview we can pull
that clip for later when he was talking
about when he changed on gay marriage by
the way he was against gay marriage when
he came into office okay when he came
into office him and Barack Obama were
against gay marriage yes and then he
told I don't remember if it was
Stephanopoulos he said I remember where
I was when I changed when it changed I
was with my dad and we saw I saw I
looked around I saw two men I saw two
men just kiss each other on the lips
look at that I looked at him and he said
Joe it's simple
they love each other and I'm not joking
what why do you feel when you say I'm
not joking it because it's so weird that
they were kissing each other on the lips
no it means I'm lying because I clearly
was anti-gay marriage like last week but
now I'm telling you a story about a
place I've never been uh with a
conversation that I had with my father
that never took place
um you know with people who don't exist
so in a quick timeline with with Biden
always reveals that he's lying his dad
would have been long since passed away
yeah exactly he just lies about
everything I was like when I met the
pope you didn't I mean now he did he
pooped himself at the Vatican but at one
point in time remember he lied about me
in the Poke people like why would you
see him at the pope when he was vice
president they're like you haven't met
the pope yet he's like I'm not joking
like you know you're not joking you're
lying yeah is it mental decline or do
you think it's just him lying to sound
more important or whatever it is look
I'm sorry and I've heard people like
Rogan uh make this point and I think
that a lot of people out there believe
that he was sharp when he was young he
was never sharper he was never sharp he
wasn't you know he wasn't uh
indecipherable right but he was was not
sharp it was never under the spotlight
like now so he could get away with it he
wasn't in the spotlight once when he had
to pull out of the 1988 presidential
campaign because he he lied about
somebody he plagiarized and he lied he
said I think he said he was
valedictorian of his class he finished
in the bottom five no uh second to last
and then the last guy passed away he was
laughing so borderline I was I
was top I'm not joking like well here it
says that you were here it says that you
were last but I said I wasn't joking
that doesn't just shut up
oh I don't know the rules
hard rule must be the bell curve no it's
the U curve yeah
as a matter of fact you benefit all the
other crappy students because you've
changed the curves you'd love to see Joe
Biden in the class all right by the way
we're gonna go now let's get into the
shooting uh some updates here from
Nashville hit the like button if you
were on YouTube you know commenting
helps with uh the algorithm and of
course same thing uh on on Rumble uh
migrate to rumble if you oh I should go
there if you see this at any point on
YouTube the YouTube dump button
yeah
that means that it you can watch what's
happening on Rumble but we're just not
going to self-censor and be on YouTube
okay I want that to be like my Christmas
fireplace let's just have that on the
music sometimes I want to throw you in
the Christmas fireplace why would you do
that well just because I could get the
music
okay I want to see you know you're a man
of faith I want to see if you're like a
Bendigo and I want to see if you you
know yeah okay I think you'll burn did
you just agree with that
fantastically so look here's uh here's
some updates uh from yesterday right the
Nashville uh shooting and I I think the
important Point here too is that
unfortunately you're seeing a flip and
you're seeing people on the right
Republicans use the language of the left
and that is exactly what they want terms
like hate speech which by the way will
make it very easy to transition into red
flag laws so we have to be very very
mindful in how we approach this and not
act um not react emotionally like those
on the left do as a matter of policy so
here's what we do know there was a
Manifesto left by Audrey
I'm not dead naming Audrey uh any name
for Audrey is a dead name
uh so Audrey left Manifesto with the
police are not releasing it uh what we
have seen also which is pretty important
what we now know is that Audrey Hale had
outside of the gender dysphoria outside
had an emotional disorder and was
already seeing uh Professionals for this
now to give you an idea again we talked
about this yesterday if people want to
talk about red flag laws if the left is
being genuine which is why I do not
support red flag laws because it's based
on a lie if you look at the 42 attempted
suicide rate okay up until recently the
dsm-4 had gender dysphoria listed as a
mental illness in other words political
pressure and then they switched it where
gender dysphoria though they're the
symptoms of someone born in the wrong
body dsm-4 was gender dysphoria itself
was like body dysmorphia like anorexia
right it was a psychiatric condition
they said oh no it's not a condition
they're the symptoms now someone being
born in the wrong body no proof ever
that there's a male brain and a female
body or vice versa there has been no
proof every study actually proves the
opposite just to be clear so I will go I
will consider it because there's been no
evidence to change it a psychiatric
condition okay gender dysphoria but
there's something called comorbidities
which is why this emotional distress
disorder is relevant with uh with Audrey
here they're found in at least 50 to 70
percent of all gender dysphoria
diagnosis wow so things like anxiety
disorder substance abuse major
depressive disorder uh impulse control
disorders uh irrational phobias
adjustable disorders one of them Eating
Disorders so these are everywhere this
is very common and it's very very well
known again this is a lie that is agreed
upon people say oh they just need to
live their true life it's because
they're discriminated against again you
didn't see this level of comorbidities
with American slaves you didn't and we
don't even need to go uh back that far
you don't see it with black Americans
which everyone talks about how black
Americans are still being systematically
discriminated against I don't believe
their systemic racism but if you believe
that why is there not a 42 attempted
suicide rate why is there not the same
level of comorbidities that you see 50
to 70 percent by the way that's a
conservative number hey what about gays
with AIDS in the 80s
don't have that suicide rate don't have
those comorbidities and it was a literal
death sentence
[Music]
Daniel Defense AR-15 okay and how would
you rate your mental state
[Music]
great
everybody I'm under the impression that
you cannot ask such questions sir which
by the way was the exact look of Mimi on
The Drew Carey Show because that was the
funny right moo moo with the clown
makeup yeah exactly
is all the Splendor that is woman
by the way you know that you can't use
Sun Chip oil as a lubricant for your
rifle I'll do what I want
what I want oh by the way download the
rumble app is also your best bet 10 a.m
10 a.m Easterns when you can tune the
show but if you download the app
notifications automatically work and
you'll never miss a show oh that's a
pretty cool little Stinger it is all
right better than mine but no you're
absolutely right Gerald hey put it this
way if you could have betting odds right
if you were allow if you were allowed to
bet on this let's say sports betting
that okay this person is identifying as
transgender and they would give you even
odds and you could bet if they have some
other psychiatric condition or not and
you just always bet yes you would be a
rich man absolutely you'd be a rich man
because you would win 70 of the time
well and if you're if your argument is
that guns are used for suicide so often
that you want to prevent them from
getting into the hands of people not
just that they'll go harm others which
obviously that's a major major concern
but a 42 attempted suicide rate you'd be
right like that would be fantastic you
would be right more times than not
almost right just under that
saying hey we're not going to give this
person a gun because they might just
attempt suicide with it yeah right well
anecdotally it's not a study but high
level psychiatrists you've had on the
show yes say 100 100 in every case yes
100 yeah because what happens is the
reason that you probably have 70 is you
have some psychiatrist again it's
politicized look at Public School
teachers everything is politicized
politics will come to you you have some
psychiatrists who go well that would
usually be generalized anxiety or that
would usually be major depressive
disorder but it's just a symptom of the
fact that people mistreat them because
they take they can't take a at
Talbots
so they're at talents I don't know I was
trying to think of what that where that
person was shot I have no idea online
dear God I pray they don't still have
Fredericks of Hollywood
so and here's something that I I want
you guys to be very aware of okay so we
know this now okay Manifesto that isn't
being released we know that there was a
comorbidity okay but now you have the
right playing into the left hand some
people are praising Senator Josh Hawley
here
um I am not and then I want to point
here's why anytime people use the term
hate crime it has always been used to
eventually leverage it into hate speech
laws murder doesn't need a footnote now
this is Terrorism it's not a hate crime
and you will see that on the left they
do not apply that term hate crime
equally at all it's entirely selective
so here's Senator Josh Hawley and you
can comment below I'd love if you
disagree with me committing a major
screw-up I would argue
for political points theater calling it
a hate crime Mr President we must also
tell the truth about what happened
yesterday in Nashville this murderous
rampage this taking of innocent life was
a horrific crime but more specifically
it was a hate crime nope a crime that
according to Nashville police
specifically targeted that's their word
targeted
the members of this Christian Community
the members of this religious
institution let's be clear Mr President
federal law prohibits the targeting of
violence against any American and phrase
on the basis affiliation or religious
practice or religious belief but that is
according to police exactly what we saw
happen yesterday can we rewind it a
little bit just and then pause at any
America that's where it should end this
is the problem with hate crime right
forbids the violent targeting of any
American boom done but then when you had
on the basis of well he's saying
religion in this case it would be
appropriate that would actually fall
under terrorism which already has a
qualification but the left wants to say
under the guise of or based on gender
which by the way there's thousands of
genders now right or sexual orientation
there's hundreds of sexual orientations
now right so now hate crime they can
they can just rack up a bill on you they
can just and you know what add that to
the tab as far as reasons no murder
you're not allowed to violently Target
any American yeah period so let's play
that again and just see if if you
understand why constitutionally it's
important for him to end the phrase
right here police specifically targeted
that's their word targeted
the members of this Christian Community
the members of this religious
institution let's be clear Mr President
federal law prohibits
the targeting of violence against any
Americans
that should be the end of the phrase it
should and look it's not lost on us that
there are hate crime laws on the books
and that they're not necessarily hate
speech laws on the books in the same way
that there are hate crime laws but
that's the whole point it doesn't matter
yeah right murder doesn't need a
footnote the left has proposed many many
many many speech laws which would mimic
Europe which would mimic Australia which
would mimic Canada if the left had their
way there would be hate speech laws in
the book where you could be jailed for
doing a cover of kung fu fighting at a
karaoke bar that right happened
absolutely and Hallie's trying to kind
of box Biden in a little bit here but I
understand like look that's not the
language that you need the fact that
somebody has been murdered is enough now
I understand that there are different
degrees of murder so I'm not addressing
that because there are legitimate
reasons for that but whether I was
pissed off at you because you cut me off
in traffic or because you were a race
that I didn't like doesn't matter I
murdered you right I don't understand
what we're trying to accomplish by
saying you're legislative that's
specialty murder you get an additional
five years for an additional 10 years
that's not going to stop somebody from
committing the crime an additional
additional vial of lethal injection yeah
no it that's legislation which almost
seems redundant but yes but I didn't
know what these guys were supposed to be
wearing they're more
you know most of them are lawyers and if
he just said hey
um and I normally like what Holly has to
say but if I were advocating for my
friends on the other side of the aisle I
might say yeah but no he speaks as
though okay it's about scoring it's
about scoring clicks online where people
go yeah hey by the way stronger word is
Terrorism so let me explain this to you
why you don't need to hate let me read
uh to you uh the actual definition uh
how the FBI I guess defines I know
you're saying FBI but I'm just using it
because these are the laws how they
Define characterize a hate crime it says
a criminal offense motivated by bias
against the victim's race religion
disability sexual orientation ethnicity
gender or gender identity and Race by
the way doesn't count if you're white
right so that's very very broad but
here's the thing we already have a
definition of terrorism
so all hate crimes is expanding that
just like we talked about with Tick Tock
it's expanding that Authority here's the
FBI's definition of terrorism which I
think this shooting would meet violent
criminal acts committed by individuals
and or groups to further ideological
goals stemming from domestic influences
such as those of political religious
social racial or environmental nature
boom this qualifies the only difference
is hate crime basically adds
specifically sexual orientation
ethnicity gender gender identity nope
it's terrorism it's terrorism it was
targeting someone based on their
religion in order to try and intimidate
people of a political point of view and
I know I know that there are a lot of
Muslims across the globe thinking you
had a monopoly on it you know what you
feel like you have to up your game but
you don't just take this take this as an
opportunity to you know curb it a little
bit do take some you time do some
self-reflection yeah and I've seen a lot
of people on the right sharing you know
different memes and things about this is
hate crime and you know if your skin
color was in this range it's not and if
it's in this range it is you know that
kind of thing and it's just like guys
look I get it I understand what people
are doing totally get it I understand it
but don't lean into that it's not about
hip-hop you don't say hey look they're
Hypocrites so let's do the same thing
what you want to point out everyone's a
hypocrite and I've talked about this
many many times it's not that they're
hypocrite it's that they don't believe
it a hypocrite can believe what they say
and fall short of their standards you
can believe that it's wrong to drink to
be to drink in excess and be an
alcoholic you're a hypocrite doesn't
mean that you say hey it's fine to be an
alcoholic the problem is when you say
for example hey it's so dangerous
everyone has to lock down and you're
going to get a perm like Nancy Pelosi
that is a hypocrisy that she doesn't
believe it and now I want to lay out the
case for you the left doesn't believe it
so you give them the authority for the
hate crime moniker well this certainly
would qualify if you're using their
standards which we don't here's Biden's
response when not talking about ice
cream asked whether he thought
Christians were specifically targeted
the realm of hate crime
is
that Christians
I have no idea Josh Hawley believes they
were what do you say to that
no I have no idea
no idea by the way you notice that
people say oh why does everything
politicize the former vice president
Josh Hawley said this then I probably
don't no I'm kidding uh yeah but you
always say you're kidding you're not
kidding and it's like it's like it's
like opposite day the kid who shows up
on Wednesday at school the third
Wednesday of every month wearing a shirt
in Reverse it's like okay Tommy it's not
that clever this is not something to
joke about though this is not something
to go do stand up about ice cream and
making fun of the fact that you forget
your name and that your wife's not the
president of the United States and
neither is the vice president United
like you this is not the time to do that
the time to do this say you know we're
looking into it right now we take this
matter very seriously and we will get to
the bottom of this yeah and we will find
out well but he kind of means that it
frames in his argument I know what did
he say then no no I don't believe that
it's easy for me I was kidding right
there was only six people dead Kamala
Harris didn't really have a lot of touch
she wasn't able to respond her hands
were full with mayor's wieners so she's
down to Mayors not even Governors
wow she took a step how the mighty had
fallen boy as you said the other day
don't be afraid to dream bigger yeah
don't be afraid to dream bigger
sweetheart I remember when they asked
out what was it was it Willie Brown was
the mayor was that who it was yeah San
Francisco yeah on Kamala Harris and then
I'm going to get back to the hate crime
thing but they asked they asked and uh
guys here I got my notes Here I want to
make sure it's not everything's jumbling
all around
um when they asked uh the mayor they
said uh hey uh did you sleep with Kamala
Harris basically his response was like I
banged a lot of
some people are saying that you slept
with her and gave her that uh that
Municipal job isn't it could be
sounds like something I would do ain't
nothing go change
so here right there he said I don't know
I don't know uh I don't know what it is
I have no idea okay so here's an
important question is it applied equally
the Buffalo Supermarket shooting by the
way it was labeled a hate crime
immediately by the media the day after
wow the Pittsburgh synagogue shooting
was labeled the day of the shooting so
they have responded in the past of
course when it serves their political
their political agenda they immediately
say hate crime hate crime hate crime we
need stronger laws on hate crime and of
course they also have laws waiting in
the wings on hate speech when it's very
clear and there's a Manifesto that this
was targeting of Christians and by the
way that even the media has carried the
waters saying this is because of the
anti-trans bill which of course we
talked about yesterday was completely
misrepresented uh we don't know if it's
hate crime we're a little bit murky on
the motivation has there ever been
outside of Islamic terrorism a more
clear-cut motivation for a shooting yeah
as I
evil as heinous it may be has there ever
been a more clear-cut example I mean
here's the thing the left and the right
are saying the same thing the writer
saying well this is motivated this was
terrorism it was motivated by hatred of
Christianity and the left is saying you
know if Christians and you people on the
right wouldn't push these people to the
brink of society this wouldn't have
happened
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hate crimes and if you think it's a good
thing if you support Josh Hawley again
I'm not saying that Josh Hawley is a bad
guy I'm not saying hasn't been a lot of
good I just think this is a really big
misstep which by the way we'll get to
with the tick tock bill yeah because we
all start with the kernel of Truth and
then it veers off and here's something
too uh just to to offer some some praise
some some credit and a lot of other
people have been doing this but I think
that again the rule of contrast is
important knowing that the response time
was relatively good is is not the same
as understanding the entirety uh of the
context in well if we compare to like
Uvalde for example so the emergency call
was received at 10 13 a.m uh took 10
minutes for officers to arrive okay then
it took three minutes for the police to
kill the shooter let's compare that to
the uh now do we have a side by side yes
side by side of Nashville versus Uvalde
there's no audio there's no audio okay
just watch it
big difference
if you notice something on the left it's
uh called The Fast Forward yeah yeah we
had to do a time lapse we almost played
the uh the Benny Hill music for Uvalde
but uh realized it would be considered
in poor taste yes yeah I think 24
minutes is what they're doing right
there yes exactly I think the point is
they're they're hapless Rubes using the
hand sanitizer yep well look gotta keep
saying Safety First
no your job is and by the way here's the
big difference these police officers on
the right
they understand that their job when
called to do it is to die
to protect their fellow citizens
we're still used to cubicle work and not
no no hold on a second you're if you're
a soldier
out in the battlefield if you're a
police officer
you have signed up to when there are
children being murdered your job is to
hopefully make that guy die first but
accept the risk yeah that it's part of
your job description to die in the
effort of battle to save their lives and
those guys were willing to do it yeah
100 like and by the way if you don't
want to sign up for that that's totally
fine I understand it don't sign up right
right if that's not what you're willing
to do yeah but think about this three
minutes
from arriving on the scene to Shooter is
down three minutes yeah wow this
shooting in Uvalde wasn't resolved and
you saw the people piling up in the
hallway and there's probably a bunch of
good officers there that wanted to go in
that for whatever reason didn't for
orders whatever it was
but three minutes later these guys go in
and methodically clear clear clear clear
boom Shooters down done good no no more
innocent people are dying today yep
this is why I always say you know they
believe that a gun is evil I don't even
say that killing is evil just to be
clear
you can kill kids
or you can kill
the psychopath killing kids violence is
amoral let's be clear about that if you
do not teach children right from wrong
none of these things are relevant if
someone doesn't understand right from
wrong they have violence bad no no
because then that then that means when
push comes to shovel when they have to
pull that trigger to save lives of
potentially countless people
they don't do it because violence is
wrong it's like the zero tolerance
policies that we used to have at school
with bullies that's the less extreme
version if you fight back if you push
the bully who was beating up on a
helpless person if a bully is beating up
on a handicapped kid and you punch that
bully in the face you both get treated
equally that was the that was the policy
at my high school that sends the wrong
message for crying out loud that kid
that kid if he punches the bully should
get you know week-long access to to Joe
Biden's ice cream Fritch
well now look you made a really good
point we were talking about this earlier
three minutes is phenomenal right but
it'd be better it's not as good as zero
minutes exactly it's not as good as zero
minutes which when people say hey why or
you want to have a world where we have
armed guards at school yeah
yes I do and I want every teacher who
wants to have a firearm who keeps it in
a Sit you know who has it locked or some
kind of a retention holster they should
have the right to they shouldn't forfeit
their right if they choose to carry a
firearm if they are a teacher yeah
absolutely and here you know what 16
mass shootings have our school shootings
have occurred this year alone 19 if you
include after grade you know go all the
way through college but 16 of those K
through 12. yeah so it seems like we can
solve a we can
you maybe give 16 different groups of
people a better shot at surviving yeah
if we just allow that to happen instead
of making these gun free zones which is
absolutely ridiculous no no it's far
more realistic to get rid of over the
400 million guns in this case
we're just even talking about if you
don't like guns okay fine let's say that
you got a full-on gun ban tomorrow let's
just from a pragmatic standpoint again
it's unconstitutional but let's say you
could do that still is it 400 something
million guns in circulation I believe
right now in the United States yeah what
do you do with those so you think if if
you want to take steps right now what
can you do right now to plug the hole
right if you're in a boat what can you
do right now okay
get rid of 400 something million guns in
this country not to mention how many of
those used are illegally procured like
in the south side of Chicago or right
now can you put some people with guns in
schools who know how to use them
responsibly by the way 100 of mass
Shooters are stopped by someone with a
gun their own a police officer's gun or
being taken into custody at gunpoint
absolutely so really quickly we have a
clip if you want to show it to
Indianapolis if a good guy stopping a
bad guy with a gun just to kind of
highlight that point yeah and by the way
there's so many of these we almost don't
because it happens all the time there's
two million defensive uses of firearms
each year is that why you're raising a
hand no I was going to say that that
response time metric is not the key it's
important but I mean Nashville is a big
city yeah evolved a more rural really
yeah it's that engagement number that's
what three minutes yeah once they arrive
boom what do we do you know they're so
worried about the police arrived quickly
and did nothing for a long time that's
right that's a key metric yeah that's a
good point yeah that's a very big and
that's a character issue that's a
character issue we have a soul issue in
this country if you're a cop and you
show up imagine that imagine being
because we watch it and there's no sound
okay and I want to go to this clip but
imagine Uvalde and it you know it
literally makes me sick to my stomach
especially now as a dead imagine being
there a police officer showing up was it
an hour it was almost an hour almost an
hour hearing the guns going on so they
had sound yeah they heard the bullets
flying they heard the screams of
children
and they're waiting for their supervisor
they're putting on hand sanitizers
that's a soul issue that's a sole issue
oh they have to take no no no no no no
no no orders go out the window when
there are bullets flying and kids dying
in there that is a character issue and
the difference between a valley sure we
have policy issues but we also have a
soul issue we have a cowardice issue and
so it does deserve praise uh the
Nashville police officers look it's not
their fault that they weren't stationed
there beforehand but when they showed up
guess what they said not today not
happening here that's the difference of
their character but you can't we can't
talk about that can't talk about that
because then that that would be a
judgment and then that judgment might
apply to ooh oh my gosh people with
mental illness who identify as you know
a a trans old lady or maybe from The
Drew Carey Show we have another uh clip
you said that yeah from Indianapolis
good guy with a gun stuffing a bad guy
with a gun it's just one example of the
two to three million defensive uses of
firearms every single year
another American mass shooting with a
rare twist after authorities near
Indianapolis say a Good Samaritan armed
with a handgun shot the gun
many more yeah this I think that we
actually had the video of it oh no no no
no sorry it was just show the video I I
don't know but basically showing the
point like look this is what happens
somebody on scene who's got you know
just a Good Samaritan this is not a
police officer or anything like that to
kind of Butters the point we just made
yeah able to take out this person very
very quickly yeah before more people are
killed yeah and the shooters are real to
respond Shooters at a real disadvantage
he's looking at maybe hundreds of people
at the food right he doesn't know where
it's coming from and we all focus on him
right that's yeah that's a big thing
that's the concealed carry that's why
there's such a benefit there is they
have no idea it's surprised you win a
lottery yeah and if but if you're
a police officer today you need to sit
in your quiet time and say okay
purpose in my purpose in your heart in
advance how will I handle this if it
ever happens to me it might be friends
that's a we watch violent videos all the
time of fights and we go okay what would
I do yeah don't you put yourself in so
much
on that Subway pension yeah seriously in
advance that's not how would you respond
well yeah people want the benefits and
they want the security and they want the
pensions and they they want the vacation
with a lot but they don't want the risk
they don't want the risk that's what a
police officer does it's not going to be
a huge part of your job but you have to
decide in advance what it is that you're
going to do it is a sole issue and by
the way the easiest rebuttal whenever
someone says just so the fastest path to
victory for you guys uh when someone
says well what if what if if it would
save one life won't it say say
yeah but it will it will take Millions a
year
two to three defensive two to three
million defensive pieces of firearms so
so yours so you say Save a Life you mean
14 000 I believe in 2020 where gun
homicides most of them are great but
just say yeah yeah but there are
millions saved so so why do you want to
take millions of lives there you go done
you now remove the whole empathy
argument and it's disingenuous anyway
all right and by the way you can hit
like button smash the rumble button
whatever it is that you want to do where
you're watching recommend that you head
on over to rumble because boy is it has
it been exciting uh this is another
thing uh Rhonda Santos and by the way if
you're listening on audio we're about to
get in some stuff that doesn't make
sense
oh I should tell you audio by the way on
audio uh Friday if you're not subscribed
to Spotify or you know Apple it's not
iTunes anymore Apple wherever audio is
we are uploading uh the Lost yeah the
Lost sketches or like four 600 audio
sketches back before this was ever on
YouTube that we found we've archived and
you get an episode there on Friday and
it's only available there uh because
they don't really make sense unless
you're listening on audio we'll be doing
that the next two Fridays then the rest
of it will be available for download on
mug Club it's finally flipped we're
listening on audio is an advantage yeah
well for this one yeah
one day a week just yeah just one day
one day but there's hundreds we still
have to go through and by the way
they're not all gyms
um a lot of them was filler yeah Monday
you have 16 minutes of ads on AM radio
and you just have to fill it because
you're like oh my God
such an archaic medium which we'll get
to with John Leguizamo or as icon no
Talent nothing no and he would call home
when he needed guests yes I would I'm
like Dad I need you to play tell a story
I need you to play the Ebolas are
did that back in the day was anyone
we're just calling okay so uh Monday uh
Governor Ron DeSantis signed a new bill
by the way um that would in this this
bill is about school choice and this is
something yeah we talk about common
ground hey how about instead of just
giving money directly to the school that
money that you spend for people is
attached to the student so they can take
it to whichever school they want that
seems like a very very reasonable
approach here's a clip State of Florida
is number one when it comes to education
freedom and education choice and
everybody
did the black guy and black woman like
plan the same hairdo and today's Bill
signing cements us in that number one
position because we will be signing
legislation which will represent the
largest expansion of Education choice
not only in the history of this state
but in the history of these United
States
big deal okay I'm not a conspiracy
theorist but this is where I would say
those are paid those are paid actors why
just bring up the still every single
white or brown or you know your guess as
good as mine kid has the same exact
haircut the Zoomer here and then every
black person has the same haircut huh
it's Zoomer sideshow
bring it up bring it up that was way too
fast look at that every single white kid
has he look one right there the white
guy with the the shorter guy is a little
different yeah yeah well he's a little
kid but not really that much every
single white guy to his left
by the way by the way with with as far
as the Optics put one black person on
your left don't put that like it's just
and then there's that one there's that
one white picture there in the middle I
don't know what her saying is
uh
it's like all right I want all the white
kids with the hairdo you're all here and
then you two African-Americans are the
same hair you're gonna go there this is
gonna be good for us this will look
great so it's the Zoomer hairstyle it's
bizarre yeah give me the sideshow Bob
yeah I think it's now known as a Rachel
dolezal oh yeah uh so DeSantis by the
way a set of the in this program just so
you know it just means that all students
now are eligible for uh School vouchers
you can go back to 2009 on YouTube where
I was advocating I did a whole video
with puppets and one was uh suspended on
YouTube because a puppet got stabbed
with a pen
he's serious it was called it was called
schools for fools and I had a Bear in
the Big Blue House costume 2009 you can
go back and watch I was advocating for
student vouchers which means that
instead of you spending money just going
to a school it means that the voucher
attaches to the student they can take it
to a school of their choice now the left
says that's racist and of course the
response is that makes no sense you're
but
the bill as DeSantis described he said
now primarily there will be a preference
for low and middle income families but
at the end of the day we fundamentally
believe the money should follow the
student and be directed on what the
parent thinks is the most appropriate
education program for their child that
really common common ground come on
again if it's not about control from the
left tell me how when they try to say
it's racist tell me how the black kid in
the inner city who has to go to one of
the crappiest schools in the country
doesn't benefit from at least having a
choice absolutely oh you know what it
does is it breaks the teachers unions
that's what it is exactly they say well
what about black kids in bad
neighborhoods they can't travel to other
schools well guess what really they've
been traveling to crappy schools for
decades that haven't improved the
metrics have shown that they've gotten
worse at least now they can ride a bike
maybe walk maybe that school will offer
some kind of a municipal bus system at
right now there's no choice no choice
you're saying there's no benefit to some
choice so to get access to a better life
you have to potentially find a way to
travel
30 minutes in a day
I mean every old person Story I Heard
was that they walked to school and it
took longer and it was uphills both ways
in the snow the whole thing yeah what
point is it like I can't make May drink
water I can only tell you that it's for
the air if you're dying of thirst make
your way to it yeah and I get about your
children and I understand about talking
about a five-year-old though you know
but that's what we are talking here's
what they're here's what the left is is
almost at that point what they're saying
is you have a lot of kids in inner
cities don't have parents that's what
they're saying they're saying kids in
their cities don't have parents they're
not going to help them transport so what
we want is the teachers unions to be
strengthened we have to we want to put
them in a crap hole where um I think
it's one out of four black Americans
don't graduate it might be higher than
that in Detroit your chance of
graduating high school your chance of
ending up in prison is greater than
graduating high school once you enter
High School in Detroit that's a video
that I did again back in 2000 now we've
been covering this for a very very very
very long time so this is by the way a
few things that DeSantis has done March
2022 we signed the parental uh Rights
bill right the education Bill uh Disney
of the self-governing powers over there
which was kind of pretty uh pretty cool
and um oh wait a second hold on a second
while we're talking about Florida we're
actually getting word right now that the
um the uh seaweed Island oh no that has
been moving in yeah
that's moving in yes
[Music]
so we're getting uh getting in my
earpiece breaking news that actually um
it has made there's been there have been
some updates so let's check back in with
uh our on the ground correspondent uh
Finnegan and see what he has
[Music]
okay Finnegan hi Stephen I've been out
here for a while and I could confirm
that the seaweed has moved closer to the
beach and it's four possibly five inches
closer which in metric is
it's a it's a lot so it's a slow-moving
aquatic disaster effectively
slow moving but very serious so I'm
gonna stay out here do my due diligence
and keep an eye on it
okay well I guess we'll check back in
later and watch out for that crowd
[Music]
what is that time zone difference with
Finnegan that's again well that's more
so it's just because it's the clouds or
something about that yeah that's the
stormy nights in Florida so yeah El Nino
effect in the Humboldt squid so email
Nino it's California oh you know
I had a Nanny named El Nino turns out
turns out ranfentanyl like a boss
so why'd you give me a male nanny with
neck tattoos that was weird that was
ill-advised so earlier in the face uh he
also revokes the liquor license uh
DeSantis for the Hyatt Regency by the
way and for those who don't know that's
because of Hotel refresher uh hosted
this Christmas drag show where uh
children were present
and so I'm so excited I was like it's
Christmas time I'm going to do December
36 times everyone's gonna dress up like
a sexy little bigger than I'm
gonna have to think outside the box
[Music]
okay so we're glad by the way that
DeSantis has been taking a stand here
with that Hyatt you know I don't like
the Hyatt no I don't know not a big fan
of the Hyatt but it really should only
be the start because I don't know if you
know this hotel there's an epidemic of
hotels across this country that are
they're just they're smut holes yes they
really are just a place where the yeah
the the the bottom of the barrel is the
dream's gonna die yeah this is where the
scumbags I guess for if you want to use
that yeah we can use that cretans yes
Bottom Feeders not sending them they go
to the Hyatt but not just the Hyatt
other hotels across this country have
been hyper-sexualized yeah awful which
brings us to this week seven plus one
[Music]
the chamber and this week's seven plus
one seven plus one sexually explicit
hotels that's a problem across this
country so if you see these hotels on
the side of the road just keep on moving
uh seven plus one sexually explicit
hotels number seven
Motel sex that seems actually pretty
that's yeah that's on the nose oh free
STD testing well that's nice look I mean
I don't know how much of that is a grant
and bring your own sheets at that hotel
yeah and black light avoid the pool
seven plus one sexually explicit hotels
number six uh the holiday Holiday Inn
[Music]
exactly people on audio this makes no so
these are all these are all photoshops
uh hey Pops Crowder let's go number five
one of my favorites the extended gay
America oh yeah well that's good too
they cut they actually they have stoves
there so you can like a little mini
kitchen yeah you can cook or hide a body
seven plus one sexually explicit hotels
number four the heart well the hard
hotel which is just that's yeah yeah
it's more of a casino and resort don't
steal the towels must be the steam from
the AC units on the top sexually
explicit hotels seven plus one number
three Gerald a the red poof Inn yeah
it's an international expression
it means magic it does
seven plus one sexually expressed hotels
look yesterday was intense you guys this
is this is for all of you number two the
Best Western Role Play Dungeon that just
seems like more of a descriptor yes yeah
really number one
this is really more of a motel but you
know we we had to yeah we had to include
all of them I mean basically it's a
place to rest your yeah place to rest
your Noggin or engage in debauchery
right uh seven plus one the number one
uh hotel to avoid is the super eight
inches which you're getting whether you
want it or not and that's a problem the
plus one seven plus one social explosion
hotels is oh actually well that makes
it's the Paris Hilton
that's been this week's seven plus one
[Music]
in the chamber you always forget one
yeah absolutely the Super 8 inches by
the way I think is no longer under Asian
ownership
it's by the Chicago mayoral game today
well yeah
nothing gonna change you guys need to
watch the Chicago Mayors on CNN all the
time yes if I may have Chicago I will
put on more gun restrictions mm-hmm
okay Ain't Nothing Gonna Change
it's going insane everywhere is a Gun
Zone yeah everywhere is a Gun Zone
because it's a gun free zone vote for me
you get to keep your gun violence free
guns for everybody you just he's
parenting exactly what they already do
in Chicago am I the only one hilarious
all right so here let's go into this
because some people uh weren't aware
what we were talking about was the
hearing on Monday yeah The Tick Tock
hearing that's very different
from the bill yes now from the
legislation which is worrisome if you
don't know about this uh I would highly
recommend that you go and read it right
and there were multiple that were being
floated actually this is where Holly
kind of makes up for his earlier thing
he actually had a better version of this
that he was trying to get to be the one
taken up but it wasn't so hey guys do we
have can you guys give me also the the
vote uh what we have from Republicans
and Democrats I don't necessarily know
they have the numbers because that would
be interesting yeah to actually see uh
so this is the uh restrict Act Right
Congress right there's been support or
has it it hasn't gone it hasn't gone
through that's right it hasn't gone
through I don't know if there was a
they're still proposing different
proposing but I read somewhere there's
like the list of people who they expect
to support it yes and it's surprisingly
well it's like co-sponsors and sponsors
and people that have signed on to it so
far so it just hasn't gone yet isn't it
so funny that we just sort of accept the
idea of earmarks
you hear this a lot this is one of those
things because I get if you're tuning
into the show you might not necessarily
be a political junkie earmarks right
that means that you can have a bill okay
that everyone sort of wraps up they read
it and then they go oh yeah and by the
way just hold on a second what I just
added 100 million more for a a thing
that nobody else knows about good enough
for me is it in your District yes yes
yeah yeah yeah oh good
and the bill can be triple the size like
yeah this is just something we do a lot
of people don't you hear the term
earmarks it quite literally means they
can just add what they want and people
go oh that's one another one of them uh
earmarks hmm no
how about no I'd be like filing an
expense report at work like okay so this
is your gas uh-huh right okay and then
this was your mileage uh-huh yeah wait
what's this that's the bill for my whole
car I just figured I'd want to put that
in there it's like all right take care
of it all it's the law that would be
something if you put to a referendum 90
of the country would say but we do that
yeah of course not well that's the thing
is they're not actually Representatives
on the issues that they should represent
you yeah that's one of those issues
where the people should be able to say
the people should be able to control
their representatives right they should
be able to Corral them they can't
necessarily vote on every single piece
of legislation they're a representative
government but you certainly should be
able to vote on the rules regulating
your representatives so it should do
something that you think they're going
to vote to get rid of earmarks it's it's
basically it's it's free money anyway
sorry I go off on I went off on a
tangent there
you guys comment below what you think
about earmarks maybe there's so maybe
there's one guy there who's like I am
super appropriate bro you're marked bro
oh I've now met you Pro earmark Todd
well it's not always an Appropriations
thing sometimes it's just a an
ideological thing where and you have to
vote against it because someone else
stuck something in there yeah that
you're against and by the way he voted
down exactly that's another it's a
political tool as well there you go okay
all right this is the for example this
is the don't Smack uh babies that aren't
yours or yours Bill like don't slap
babies in the face bill which anyone
would support right be like oh okay okay
that's good yeah and they would say oh
we have unanimous support on Capitol
Hill right but then AOC puts in like and
by the way free for children and
you're like no no no no they go you
believe in slapping babies that's right
how dare you sir
well I'm not signing it unless that's in
there yeah I'm not finding unless that's
in there oh gosh and well she has a
vested interest too that's why she was
slapped a lot that's why she's googly so
[Laughter]
here's the most popular choice of The
Tick Tock proposed bills and really one
that you should be aware of it's the
restrict act but he's talking about Tick
Tock and the ability of that platform to
be used by the Communist Party both the
take on data but also potentially as a
malign influence and propaganda tool we
need a more comprehensive approach to
evaluating and mitigating these threats
posed by these foreign Technologies from
these adversarial Nations their strict
act would give the Secretary of Commerce
the authority and the responsibility to
identify and counter threats from
foreign technology products and services
in the U.S a series of mitigation
tools given to the secretary up to and
including the opportunity demand truth
is with 100 million Americans daily on
tick tock on an average of 90 minutes a
day
this is this is an issue okay just to be
clear my position is uh if if we know
beyond any shadow of a doubt that there
is no spying and that your privacy is
entirely protected then okay then you
don't need to ban Tick Tock the issue is
the privacy and security of Americans
because I don't trust the Communist
Chinese party any further than I can
throw them so when people just say oh
you're probably a pro Free Speech until
no no this isn't a speech issue it's an
actual security issue right now the
problem is that's used by those on the
left and those fake uh Republicans to
then shoehorn in uh a total Invasion
ironically of your privacy and security
so it's been introduced by Mike Warner
okay who's a republican uh sorry
Democrat from Virginia and John soon
Republican South Dakota it's named the
restricting the emergence of security
threats that risk information and
Communications technology act jeez I
hate the way they name these things can
you please just name it something simple
and easy for us yeah that's that's too
long because they're always naming it
for the acronym but it's the restrict
act it's the restrict act good I hope
someone just accidentally spells one
it's like the I'm an
let the Democrats name it because
they're better with language than we are
you know Affordable Care Act pro-choice
yeah they're real sure affirming chaos
we need better marketing on these bills
uh so March 7th a bill was introduced by
the way weeks before the hearing just to
clear other sponsors of the bill include
Mitt Romney
I'm gonna pull up I'm gonna pull a Biden
with mid round if like if he's for it
I'm probably against it now is that the
Michigan Mitt Romney you're the no no no
no no yeah
the Utah carpet bagger yes yes yes not
to be confused with uh with muncher yes
that's a totally different animal that's
Rosie O'Donnell and she's not in office
I don't even know why you brought that
up Gerald weird so the
National Security advisor Jake Sullivan
praised the bill saying this legislation
would empower the United States
government to prevent certain foreign
governments from exploiting technology
Services operating the United States uh
United States okay that sounds great
that sounds great stopping the CCP from
spying on us through Tick Tock great
okay I agree with that that's what we
talked about on Monday but the details
of the bill well a lot of them have
nothing to do with that so here's a let
me give you I think it's three kind of
fast facts so you know and you can check
all references at lottery.com here's
fact number one okay
the bill is incredibly broad now here's
the purpose of the legislation it's
described as uh authorizing the
Secretary of Commerce and that's going
to come back this is key here get ready
to put your tinfoil hat on because the
end of this segment before we go to
rumble I mean this Tim can about to hit
is it it's going to knock out a couple
of teeth all right to authorize a
secretary of Commerce to review and
prohibit certain transactions between
persons in the United States and foreign
adversaries and for other purposes I
love that last part and and for other
purposes what purposes
it could be anything in there it was
like why do we allow laws what are your
purposes you mean like paying for
Congressional bowling alley well I
didn't expect you to pay for a whole
damn bowling alley for whatever purposes
we want yes and other things that we
cannot as much flowery language as they
use these bills as long as these things
are they're like
and other stuff and other stuff well
hold on a second what do you plan on
purchasing it's a lamp what a great lamp
how much did it cost a taxpayer 14 000
yeah there's a little bit of red really
there so what exactly constitutes a
transaction here we go and we're joking
about it but here's here's the technical
term and what we just said was just as
accurate of a description the term cover
transaction includes any other
transaction son of a
the structure of which is designed or
intended to evade or circumvent the
application of this act which by the way
is designed to restrict transactions so
any transactions would be intending to
evade or circumvent the application of
this act subject to regulations
prescribed by the secretary okay here's
the crazy thing okay here's another fast
fact for you that might blow your mind
under this bill right defining all the
terms and the punishments of these
transactions uh it's up to the Secretary
of Commerce uh uh Gina raimondo okay now
the secretary just to be clear so this
is where they talk about the
authorization yeah okay now secretary is
quote authorized to and shall take
action to identify deter disrupt prevent
prohibit investigate or otherwise
mitigate
[Laughter]
entering into or imposing and enforcing
any mitigation measure to address the
risk no need for Congressional approval
hey remember where we've been this oh
remember the wars that you guys all
loved and supported and no one regrets
that later on here's what's so odd right
we're talking about the Secretary of
Commerce
said just a couple of weeks ago here's a
quote said passing a law to ban a single
company is not the way to deal with the
issue referring to tick tock the
politician in me thinks you're literally
going to lose every voter under 35. so
we are giving all of the Power regarding
all of the transactions online
to someone who doesn't want to ban tick
tock all in the name of banning tick
tock
hmm
think about that so this is what happens
this is why you don't trust your
institutions right and then they'll
blame us they'll blame the media no you
don't trust me because yeah a Chinese
spyware that's a bad thing I know Eric
schwaba was you know getting BJ's in the
back of his Sex Dungeon with like 19
Chinese Buffs I think we should probably
keep that to a minimum and we go hey
yeah good comments we say hey
Representatives can you help us I go yes
yes we can ban Tick Tock great and I go
here's the bill wait a second this has
been this band's like ever this is all
transactions and you're giving the power
to a woman who didn't even want to ban
Tick Tock and wait she can and my
PayPal's been shut down how did that
happen well you said you wanted 12 well
to stop banging Chinese spies didn't you
what didn't say how how did we get here
no it makes perfect sense it'll just
give me all of the power to do this
right right and by the way download the
rumble app that's your best bet to watch
this show right now no Chinese spyware
by the way you can uh you can get that
in the uh the App Store as long as they
allow it
it's exactly my point we'll come back to
that there's a very simple way to take
care of this right
wait take care of take care of them they
can just download the rumble app no no
no I'm saying that the rumble app is
available in the App Store why don't you
just go to the App Store providers and
say hey this is violating your terms of
use or terms of service oh they're using
this personal information you can just
remove them from the App Store a problem
is probably 80 solved see I was just
still on download the rumble app but you
were several you were playing 40 apples
also I have an app to play chess nice
the computer always I'd lose every time
so uh here's your number it's really
good I don't know I set it to extra hard
mode yeah I said it's a five-year-old
mode yes I make myself feel better and I
just imagine Bobby Fischer on a
smartphone like screw this guy all right
so uh here's another fast Factor you
know
again let's provide you some context all
references are available at
lottocredit.com is there any kind of
precedent for this well remember the
Patriot Act
after 9 11 Congress passed the Patriot
Act with by the way overwhelming
bipartisan support and at one point in
time you probably would have counted me
amongst them
to my Everlasting shame we've talked
about this it basically removed the need
for agencies like the FBI to prove any
kind of probable cause right the search
order would be granted as long as the
FBI certifies that the search is quote
to protect against International
terrorism right the FBI would not need
to meet the stronger standard of
probable cause so what happened with the
Patriot Act was in the name of National
Security right they could now listen to
your phone calls they could now you know
search in seizures they could violate
your constitutional rights and people
there's been a rebound effect where
people say oh maybe we went too far with
that now we're applying this digitally
and not just to terrorist threats but
transactions yeah transactions if they
suspect that there might be something
dealing with an international entity by
the way you combine this combine this
with a centralized digital currency that
the government wants it's game over it's
game over for the country absolutely and
do me a favor research team I think I'm
thinking of this name correctly but I'm
going to sound like an idiot if I'm not
but with the Patriot Act wasn't there
something also called like magic lantern
or something like that that they were
using to gather all of the the phone
call information to be able to listen to
that that was kind of piggybacked off of
that as well under the guise of national
I think it's something like a dragon and
that was his friend who lived by the sea
well the puff no that was the hotel
that's not possible it's magic
is it right yeah it's a magic lantern
here revealed the report of FBI's new
key logging Trojan analysis it's
possible treatment in adamic legal
landscape so yeah that's right so that
this this is not that the the Patriot
Act was the first thing and then other
things just come right after it same
thing with this right you're opening the
door hey by the way do you know how I
know that Mike Pence is never going to
be within sniffing distance of the
presidency here he is right now on CNN
Pence non-committal on if he will appeal
order to testify let's see what they say
really quickly but he did that's a woman
a little bit of a win here uh in that he
did get to to have the judge agree with
him that the vice presidency does have
some protections around it particularly
the protections that members of Congress
have boy these politicians don't this is
how this is why Donald Trump will
probably get the nomination yeah these
politicians don't know how to deal with
it well you just do is you say no go
screw yourself even if you don't like
Trump personally pens you go go screw
yourself I'm done look I'm done I did
what I did yeah you know what yeah eat
my that's what you do he said he's such
a post he has no chance I mean good
values guy for sure but he's he's the
guy isn't his personality ever make a
comment like that thank you so much I
should like him and I don't yeah so uh
the restrict act going back to this by
the way it gives by the bizarrely
similar powers to the Commerce Secretary
this is what it says she can designate
any entities for an adversary without
notifying Congress oh good hey hold on a
second as a foreign adversary what did
this Administration say was the greatest
threat to our national security at one
point that would be the domestic
terrorism from white people from and we
didn't even rehearse that we didn't he
just remembered white supremacy
but wait hold on a second hold on a
second you're you're running a farm
yourself you're doing homesteading oh
you might be in a militia group oh by
the way all these militia groups I mean
not counting the 75 percent of whom are
actually FBI agents they're actually
white supremacists so now the Secretary
of Commerce can decide that they're
going to spy on you because it's a
foreign adversary which of course would
also include threats to National
Security right notification to Congress
yeah we also uh Declassified parents
protesting that's right the school board
that's right yes and there's nothing in
there to really protect against China I
mean there's not it I mean they're gonna
unless it goes away they're going to use
the language to go after China but there
are a lot of things that it can do I
mean you you nailed it on the head there
with cryptocurrency you can basically
say like hey we can shut off potentially
all the cryptocurrency in the world we
can shut off open source software from
everywhere else in the world like
there's a lot of problems with this that
people are like hey hey hold on this
allows for that and there's no redress
like you have to go to the DC circuit
court if you have an issue you can't
even use a foia request by the way to
find out what restrict Act is used and
then you have to make a congressional
I'm sorry you have to make a
constitutional argument right in that
case right and so there there's no real
way to hold them accountable mits on the
scene you should be yes yeah
he's he's getting he's
got the phone he's getting there in
record time with his dog on the roof
so and this by the way just so you know
you live this in real time uh because of
emergency power is being used that's why
you'll never get an accurate metric on
covet desk we couldn't get it from
Michigan right oh emergency wait hold on
how many people were actually putting
old folks homes we don't have to give
you those numbers well a second legally
you're required to actually respond to
foyer requests no no we don't because of
emergency powers in this case you
wouldn't have to basically it would be
exempt from that so you can't find out
when it's used they can spy on anybody
not just buy but then restrict your
ability to exchange money and let's go
to another one let's go to fact for you
this is what's so scary because I know
you're saying okay this was used in the
United States the Patriot Act no it's
even worse than that it is eerily
similar to the Hong Kong security Bill
yes right so let's go back to this
remember in 2020 China passed its own
overarching are you good there Tillman I
see you there yeah its own overarching
uh security Bill uh here we have a clip
well the law is being imposed by Beijing
after no meaningful consultation with
Hong Kong that's a significant change
and the law bans trees and secession
sedation subversion and indeed leaves
room for anything deemed a threat to
National Security this inevitably
changes what can and can't be said and
done in Hong Kong okay so let's compare
that to the restrict act keep in mind
restrict is an acronym
were represented by
just everything and this is the thing
too like I want to get into Power I get
that all the time I want to get into
politics I want to get into podcasting I
can't stand being in the room with
mostly I I haven't seen CPAC for about
four for four years in a row actually it
was four years spread over five because
I got violently ill and was uh I was
pooping my guts out the toilet bowl has
never recovered in DC and I was just
like I hate being here everyone is
trying to get put over by someone else
as a general rule they are not there to
represent you an exception Rand Paul and
he still irritates me but on policy
that's kind of I would say the best
example that we have it does a pretty
damn good job and it's pretty he's
remarkably consistent okay
uh here's the restrict deck the ACT is
designed to quote prohibit certain
transactions between persons in the
United States and foreign adversaries or
for other purposes again we go back to
the we just gave you the the render let
me read you the Hong Kong security law a
person who who conspires with or
directly or indirectly receives
instructions control funding or other
kinds of support from a foreign country
or an institution and by the way that
can include uh domestic citizens just
like the restrict act it is remarkably
similar to the this bill that we're
talking about the bill that was passed
there right the Hong Kong security law
and now you have the restrict act in the
United States all under the guise of
banning Tick Tock which by the way it
may or may not do right
not sure if it will accomplish the sole
purpose of this Bill yes now here's what
I will say Josh Hawley I disagree with
him on the hate crime thing earlier but
usually he gets it right he introduced
to build a band tick tock
it's called the no tick tock on United
States devices
it that's not a good acronym
it doesn't really stop but you don't
need the acronym because I see it and I
go okay I understand it no tick tock on
United States devices act I mean that's
a that's your elevator pitch you know a
republican named that yes right yeah and
you can sit down and go okay hold on a
second uh Miss uh Senator Holly yeah let
me ask you this with this bill would
Tick Tock be allowed on uh devices in
the United States no they would not all
right hold on a second but let me finish
would they be allowed on some devices in
the United States none whatsoever okay
but I have one final question would
there be some ex exceptions for the
spyware Tick Tock as it relates to
devices in the United States absolutely
not well good enough for me done I think
we've made it through today's closed
bills yes yes there we go but the other
Bill wants to have control of your
PayPal and likely access to your ring
cameras all of it without having to
notify you and it gives all the
authority to a Commerce Secretary who
doesn't want to ban Tick-Tock anyway and
by the way doesn't want to ban Tick Tock
because of a voting base of dumb under
30 year olds not even because of a moral
objection
we're so screwed
by the way the no tick tock on the
United States devices act just to make
clear it's entirely devoted to tick tock
and bite dance that's it perfect nothing
else that's all it should be that's all
it is stop giving yourself more and more
and more and more power right we don't
need Trojan Horse bills for you to go
and later and say hey we don't like the
fact that cryptocurrency is doing well
and we want to create our own and lock
out everybody else I get it it's the
biggest scam no no I understand you get
to you get to do what you want to do
with the crypto thing but every
government in the world is probably
going to introduce one yeah meaningfully
yeah of course it's already being
heavily regulated and then there's going
to be even more regulated but imagine a
centralized digital currency even the
ability to shut down all of your
currency just with the flip of a switch
you want to be in China where you can't
leave the country because you don't have
the green App instead you have the red
one because you're posting too many
memes of cats on YouTube yeah well I
don't really think it's a flip-on switch
anymore
didn't we have a gold sponsor waiting in
the wings somewhere we did yeah we told
them hell no yeah
love you they're looking better and
better we're just our our audience is in
75 so it's fine if it's part of your
divorce Diversified investment of course
but just gold like gold you ever see
this it's like I'm Bill Devane they're
saying I'm G Gordon lyddie whoever the
hell it is he's like gold has never been
worth nothing
yeah neither is Coke Zero but if I
bought it if I bought a can for two
dollars and now it's worth 25 cents I've
still lost money it's never been worth
nothing though got it
that's your pitch yeah but you took my
dollar and you cut it in half well
something to think about hey there's
been a single day it's been a silver
shortage since I was in high school by
the way yeah that's been the pitch and
I'm sure it's been going on since then
we're gonna run out of silver one day
we're using it all these electronic
devices it's been 30. actually I'll give
you one last try before because when
we're going to talk about John Leguizamo
on Rumble we have a full edition
additional 45 minutes but I have a
lighter a Zippo lighter that's sterling
silver and I've had this for a few years
right and I thought hey with inflation
in the economy and also silver like let
me go check and see how much it's worth
now uh it actually didn't increase in
value as much as everything else has
with basic inflation silver hasn't been
inflated I thought it was worth like 300
it was worth four cents more wow so I
don't know I'm not a precious metal zero
it's not zero I'm not a freshest Metals
expert but it seems I should have just
put my money uh in a Casper mattress or
a Casper sponsorship
oh are they a good mattress I have no
idea I have no idea I have no idea all
these mattresses in a box you ever open
one of those matches
oh my gosh it's just it smells
like we just we just listed up there's
been a lot of scams talked about on this
show and he's like oh the biggest scam
going mattresses oh no magic stores
mattress stores are all money laundering
schemes the mattress in a box some of
them are really good the problem is you
know like ah you can return it whenever
you want no they don't tell you you have
to roll it back up yeah
just to get it in the Box yeah if you
can fit in the Box without tearing it
you can return it right and that your
whole master bedroom smells like a
Chinatown brothel pre-refrigeration when
you open it up it's like oh it's just
the off-gassing how long is that going
to take nine weeks I don't know what you
you might die how long do I have to
return it three days if you have your
own vacuum sealer at home you'll be fine
exactly
just some kind of get the food
saver I'm trying to and then all your
food smells like mattresses
it's a rib eye no it's Serta
oh by the way before we go to rumble
actually sorry we're getting a news
update right now uh turns out that the
the Sea algae which is a big National
Security concern is um is getting closer
let's check back in with our on the
ground correspondent spread no expense
Thomas Finnegan
foreign
[Music]
okay let's give it one last go uh
Finnegan what do you got
wow
that again
[Music]
hey I just thought that my half asian
lawyer was on CNN but then I realized it
was left okay no all right uh everyone
we appreciate it uh that you guys have
tuned in here and we're going to
actually go discuss late night in the
state John leguizama I don't know if
you've heard everything that he says is
racist it's anti-christian Santa I guess
it would be hate species his show but
more so it's offensively unfunny so
we'll be talking about that taking your
chat and it's a live show Monday through
Thursday we have the Hodge twins in this
Thursday Friday on mug club we can go
and tune in uh to your uh theology is it
apologetics with Gerald uh the Gerald
apologizes apologetics all right either
way Monday through Friday that's your
best bet just set it like you used to
set TV guys because notifications don't
work you can download the app just you
know where to find us Monday through
Friday 10 a.m Eastern share it comment
help the algorithm uh but right now
we're I want to let our freak flight fly
do a little bit YouTube piss off
laughs